hello and welcome to the session
on deep learning my name is mohan and in
this video we are going to
talk about what deep learning is all
about
so this is what we are going to talk
about today our agenda looks something
like this what is deep learning
why do we need deep learning and then
what are the applications of deep
learning one of the main components the
secret sauce
in deep learning is neural networks so
we're going to talk about what is neural
network
and how it works and some of its
components like for example
the activation function the gradient
descent and so on and so forth
so that as a part of working of a neural
network we will go into little bit more
details how this whole
thing works so without much further ado
let's get started so deep learning is
considered to be a part of machine
learning so this
diagram very nicely depicts what deep
learning
is at a very high level you have the
all-encompassing
artificial intelligence which is more a
concept rather than
a technology or a technical concept
right so it is it's more of a concept at
a very high level artificial
intelligence
under the herd is actually machine
learning and deep learning and machine
learning is a
broader concept you can say or a broader
technology
and deep learning is a subset of machine
learning the primary difference between
machine learning and deep learning is
that deep learning uses
neural networks and it is suitable
for handling large amounts of
unstructured data
and the last but not least one of the
major differences between machine
learning and deep learning is that in
machine learning
the feature extraction or the feature
engineering
is done by the data scientists manually
but in deep learning since we use
neural networks the feature engineering
happens automatically so that's a little
bit of a quick difference between
machine learning and deep learning and
this diagram very nicely depicts the
relation between artificial intelligence
machine learning
and deep learning now why do we need
deep learning machine learning
was there for quite some time and it can
do a lot of stuff that
probably what deep learning can do but
it's not very good at
handling large amounts of unstructured
data like
images voice or even text for that
matter
so traditional machine learning is not
that very good at doing this it
traditional machine learning can handle
large amounts of structured data but
when it comes to
unstructured data it's a big challenge
so that is one of the key
differentiators for deep learning so
that is
number one and increasingly for
artificial intelligence
we need image recognition and we need to
process analyze images and voice that's
the reason deep learning is required
compared to let's say
traditional machine learning it can also
perform
complex algorithms more complex than
let's say what machine learning can do
and it can
achieve best performance with the large
amounts of data so
the more you have the data let's say
reference data or
label data the better the system will do
because the training process will be
that much better and last but not least
with deep learning you can really avoid
the manual process of feature extraction
those are some of the reasons why we
need deep learning some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning
has made major inroads and it is a major
area in which deep learning is applied
is healthcare
and within healthcare particularly
oncology
which is basically cancer related stuff
one of the issues with cancer is that a
lot of cancers today
are curable they can be cured they are
detected
early on and the challenge with that is
when
a diagnostics is performed let's say an
image has been
taken of a patient to detect whether
there is cancer or not
you need a specialist to look at the
image
and determine whether it is the patient
is fine or there is any onset of
cancer and the number of specialists are
limited so if we use deep learning if we
use
automation here or if we use artificial
intelligence here
then the system can with a certain
amount of the
good amount of accuracy determine
whether
a particular patient is having cancer or
not so the prediction
or the detection process of a disease
like cancer
can be expedited the detection process
can be expedited
can be faster without really waiting for
a specialist
we can obviously then once the
application
once the artificial intelligence detects
or predicts that there is an onset of a
cancer this can be cross-checked by a
doctor
but at least the initial screening
process can be automated and that is
where the current focus
is with respect to deep learning in
healthcare what else
robotics is another area deep learning
is majorly
used in robotics and you must have seen
nowadays robots are everywhere humanoids
the industrial robots which are used for
manufacturing process
you must have heard about sofia who got
a citizenship with
saudi arabia and so on there are
multiple such robots which are
knowledge oriented but there are also
industrial robots that are
used in industries in the manufacturing
process and increasingly in security and
also in defense
for example image processing video is
fed to them and they need to
be able to detect objects obstacles and
so on and so forth so that's where deep
learning is used they need to be able to
hear and make sense of the sounds that
they are hearing that needs deep
learning
as well so robotics is a major area
where deep learning is
applied then we have self-driving cars
or autonomous cars
you must have heard of google's
autonomous car which has been tested
for millions of miles and pretty much
incidentally there were of course a
couple of incidents here and there but
it is uh
considered to be fairly safe and there
are today
a lot of automotive companies in fact
pretty much
every automotive company worth its name
is investing
in self-driving cars or autonomous cars
and it is predicted that in the next
probably 10 to 15 years these will be in
production and they will be
used extensively in real life right now
they are all in
r d and in test phases but pretty soon
these will be on the road so this is
another
area where deep learning is used and how
is it used where is it used within
autonomous
driving the car actually is fed with
video
of surroundings and it is supposed to
process that information process that
video and determine if there are any
obstacles
it has to determine if there are any
cars in the site
will detect whether it is driving in the
lane
also it has to determine whether the
signal is green
or red so that accordingly it can move
forward or wait
so for all these video analysis
deep learning is used in addition to
that the training overall training to
drive the car
happens in a deep learning environment
so again
a lot of scope here to use deep learning
a couple of other applications are
mission translation so today we have a
lot of
information and very often this
information
is in one particular language and more
specifically
in english and people need information
in various parts of the world it is
pretty difficult
for human beings to translate each and
every
piece of information or every document
into all possible languages there are
probably
at least hundreds of languages or if not
more to translate each and every
document into
every language is pretty difficult
therefore we can use deep learning to do
pretty much like a real time translation
mechanism so we don't have to translate
everything and keep it ready but
we train applications or artificial
intelligence systems
that will do the translation on the fly
for example
you go to somewhere like china and you
want to know what is written on a
signboard now it is impossible for
somebody to translate that and put it on
the web or something like that so you
have an application which is trained to
translate stuff on the fly
so you probably this can be running on
your mobile phone on your smartphone you
scan this
the application will instantly translate
that
from chinese to english that is one then
there could be
web applications where there may be a
research document which is all
in maybe chinese or japanese and you
want to translate that
to study that document or in that case
you need to translate
so therefore deep learning is used in
such situations as well
and that is again on demand so it is not
like you have to translate
all these documents from other languages
into english and one shot and keep it
somewhere that is again
pretty much an impossible task but on a
neat basis so you have systems that are
trained to translate
on the fly so mission translation is
another major area where deep learning
is used then there are a few other
upcoming areas where synthesizing is
done by neural nets for example
music composition and generation of
music so you can train a neural net
to produce music even to compose music
so this is a fun thing this is still
upcoming it
needs a lot of effort to train such
neural land
it has been proved that it is possible
so this is a relatively new area and on
the same lines colorization of
images so these two images on the left
hand side is a
grayscale image or a black and white
image this was
colored by a neural net or a deep
learning application as you can see it's
done a very good job of
applying the colors and obviously this
was trained
to do this colorization but yes this is
one more
application of deep learning now one of
the major
secret sauce of deep learning is
neural network deep learning works on
neural network or
consists of neural network so let us see
what is neural network
neural network or artificial neural
network is
designed or based on the human brain
now human brain consists of billions of
small cells that are known as neurons
artificial neural networks is in a way
trying to simulate the human brain so
this is a quick diagram of biological
neuron a biological neuron consists of
the major part which is the cell nucleus
and then
it has some tentacles kind of stuff on
the top
called dendrite and then there is like a
long tail which is known as the axon
further again at the end of this action
are what are known as synapses these
in turn are connected to the dendrites
of the next neuron
and all these neurons are interconnected
with each other therefore they are like
billions of them sitting in our brain
and they're all active they're working
they based on the signals they receive
signals
as inputs from other neurons or maybe
from other parts of the body
and based on certain criteria they send
signals to the neurons at the other end
so they they get either activated
or they don't get activated based on so
it is like a binary
gates so they get activated or not
activated
based on the inputs that they receive
and so on so
we will see a little bit of those
details as we move forward in
our artificial neuron but this is a
biological neuron this is the structure
of a biological neuron
and artificial neural network is based
on the human brain
the smallest component of artificial
neural network is
an artificial neuron as shown here
sometimes is also
referred to as perceptron now this is a
very high level diagram the artificial
neuron
has a small central unit which will
receive
the input if it is doing let's say image
processing the inputs could be
pixel values of the image which is
represented here
as x1 x2 and so on each of the inputs
are multiplied by what is known as
weights which are represented as w1 w2
and so on
there is in the central unit basically
there is a summation
of these weighted inputs which is like
x1 into w1 plus x2 into w2
and so on the products are then added
and then
there is a bias that is added to that in
the next slide we will see
that passes through an activation
function and the output
comes as a y which is the output and
based on certain
criteria the cell gets either activated
or not activated so this
output would be like a zero or a one
binary
format okay so we will see that in a
little bit more detail but let's do a
quick comparison between
biological and artificial neurons just
like a biological neuron there are
dendrites and then there is a cell
nucleus and synapse
and an axon we have in the artificial
neuron as well these inputs come
like that and right if you will act like
the dendrites there is a like a central
unit which performs the summation of
these
uh weighted inputs which is basically w1
x1 w2 x2 and so on and then our bias is
added here
and then that passes through what is
known as an activation function
okay so these are known as the weights
w1 w2 and then there is a bias which
will come out here
and that is added the bias is by the way
common for a particular neuron so there
won't be like b1 b2 b3 and so on only
weights will be one
per input the bias is common for the
entire
neuron it is also common for or the
value of the bias remains the same
for all the neurons in a particular
layer we will also see this as we move
forward and we see deep neural network
where there are multiple neurons
so that's the output now the whole
exercise of training the neuron is about
changing these weights and biases as i
mentioned this artificial neural network
will consist of several such neurons
and as a part of the training process
these weights
keep changing initially they are
assigned some random values and through
the training process
the weights the whole process of
training is to come up with the optimum
values of w1 w2 and wn
and then the b for or the bias for this
particular neuron
such that it gives an accurate output as
required
so let's see what exactly that means so
the training process this is how
it happens it takes the inputs each
input is
multiplied by a weight and these weights
during training keep changing so
initially they are assigned some random
values
and based on the output whether it is
correct or wrong there is a feedback
coming back
and that will basically change these
weights until
it starts giving the right output that
is represented in
here as sigma i going from 1 to n
if there are n inputs wi into x i so
this is the product of
w1 x1 w2 x2 and so on right
and there is a bias that gets added here
and that entire thing goes to what is
known as an activation function so
essentially this is sigma of w i
x i plus a value of bias which is a b
so that entire thing goes as an input to
an
activation function now this activation
function
takes this as an input gives the output
as
a binary output it could be a zero or a
one there are of course to start with
let's assume
it's a binary output later we will see
that there are different types of
activation functions so it need not
always be
binary output but to start with let's
keep simple so
it decides whether the neuron should be
fired
or not so that is the output like a
binary output 0 or 1
all right so again let me summarize this
so it takes the inputs so if you're
processing an image for example
the inputs are the pixel values of the
image
x1 x2 up to xn there could be hundreds
of these so all of those are fed as so
these are some values and these pixel
values again can be from 0 to
56 each of those pixel values are then
multiplied with what is known as a
weight this is a numeric value
can be any value so this is a number w1
similarly
w2 is a number so initially some random
values will be assigned and each of
these weights are multiplied with the
input value
and their sum this is known as the
weighted sum
so that is performed in this kind of the
central unit
and then a bias is added remember the
bias is common for each
neuron so this is not the bias value is
not
one bias value for per input so just
keep that in mind the bias value there
is one bias per neuron so it is like
this summation
plus bias is the output from this
section this is not the complete output
of the neuron but this is a
bias for output for step one that goes
as an input to what is known as
activation function and that activation
function
results in an output usually a binary
output like a zero or a one
which is known as the firing of the
neuron
okay good so we talked about activation
function so what is an activation
function an activation function
basically takes the weighted sum which
is we saw
w1 x1 w2 x2 the sum of all that
plus the bias so it takes that as an
input
and it generates a certain output now
there are different types of activation
functions and the output is different
for different types of activation
functions
moreover why is an activation function
required it is basically required to
bring in
non-linearity that's the main reason why
an activation function is required
so what are the different types of
activation functions there are several
types of activation functions but these
are the most common ones these are the
ones that are currently
in use sigmoid function was one of the
early
activation functions but today relu
has kind of taken over so relu is by far
the most
popular activation function that is used
today but still sigmoid function is
still used in many situations these
different types of activation functions
are
used in different situations based on
the kind of problem we are trying to
solve so what exactly is the difference
between these two
sigmoid gives the values of the output
will be between 0 and 1.
threshold function is the value will be
0 up to a certain value and beyond that
this is also known as a step function
and beyond that it will be 1. in case of
sigmoid there is a gradual
increase but in case of threshold it's
like also known as a step function there
is a rapid
or instantaneous change from 0 to 1
whereas in sigmoid we will see in the
next slide there is a gradual increase
but the value in this case is between 0
and 1 as well now
relu function on the other hand it is
equal to
basically if the input is zero or less
than zero
then the output is zero whereas
if the input is greater than zero then
the output is equal to
the input and it's a little confusing
but in the next slides where we
show the relu function it will become
clear similarly
hyperbolic tangent this is similar to
sigmoid
in terms of the shape of the function
however
while sigmoid goes from 0 to 1
hyperbolic tangent goes from -1 to 1
and here again the increase or the
change
from -1 to 1 is gradual and
not like threshold or step function
where it happens
instantaneously so let's take a little
detailed look at some of these
functions so let's start with the
sigmoid function so this is the equation
of a sigmoid function which is
1 by 1 plus e to the power of minus x
so x is the value that is the input it
goes from
0 to -1 so this is sigmoid function
the equation is phi x is equal to 1 by
1 plus e to the power of minus x and as
you can see here this is the input on
the x axis
as x is what the value is coming from in
fact it can also go
negative this is negative actually so
this is the zero so this is the negative
value of x so as x is coming from
negative value towards zero the value of
the output slowly as it is approaching
zero it it slowly and very gently
increases
and actually at the point let me just
use a pen
at the point here it is it is 0.5 it is
actually
0.5 okay and slowly gradually it
increases to
1 as the value of x increases but then
as the value of
x increases it tapers off it doesn't go
beyond 1 so that is the speciality
of sigmoid function so the output value
will remain between zero
and one it will never go below zero or
above one
okay then so that is sigmoid function
now this is
threshold function or this is also
referred to as a step
function and here we can also set the
threshold in this case it is that's why
it's called the threshold function
normally it is 0 but you can also set a
different value
for the threshold now the difference
between this and the sigmoid is that
here the change is
rapid or instantaneous as the x value
comes from negative
up to zero it remains zero and at
zero it pretty much immediately
increases to
one okay so this is a mathematical
representation
of threshold function phi x is equal to
1 if x is greater than equal to 0
and 0 if x is less than 0. so for all
negative values
it is 0 which since we have set the
threshold to be 0. so
as soon as it reaches 0 it becomes 1.
you see the difference between this
and the previous one which is basically
the sigmoid where the increase from 0 to
1 is gradual
and here it is instantaneous and that's
why this is also known as a step
function
threshold function or step function this
is a relu relu is one of the most
popular activation functions today this
is the definition of relu
phi x is equal to max of x comma 0. what
it says
is if the value of x is less than 0 then
phi x
is 0. the moment it increases goes
beyond
0 the value of phi x is equal to
x so it doesn't stop at one actually
it goes all the way so as the value of x
increases
the value of y will also increase
infinitely so there is no
limit here unlike your sigmoid or
threshold or the next one which is
basically
hyperbolic tangent okay so in case of
relu remember
there is no upper limit the output is
equal to either 0
in case the value of x is negative or
it is equal to the value of x so for
example here if the value of x
is 10 then the value of y is also 10
right okay so that is relu and there are
several advantages of relu and it is
much more efficient
and provides much more accuracy compared
to other activation functions like
sigmoid and so on so that's the reason
it is
very popular all right so this is
hyperbolic tangent activation function
the function looks similar to sigmoid
function the curve
if you see the shape it looks similar to
sigmoid function
but the difference between hyperbolic
tangent and sigmoid function is that
in case of sigmoid the output goes from
zero to one whereas in case of
hyperbolic tangent
it goes from -1 to 1 so that is the
difference between
hyperbolic tangent and sigmoid function
otherwise the shape
looks very similar there is a gradual
increase
unlike the step function where there was
an instant
increase or instant change here again
very similar to
sigmoid function the value changes
gradually
from -1 to 1. so this is the equation of
hyperbolic tangent
activation function yeah so then let's
move on this is a diagrammatic
representation
of the activation function and how the
overall data how the overall progression
happens from
input to the output so we get the input
from the input layer by the way the
neural network has three layers
typically there will be three layers
there is an input layer there is an
output layer and then you have the
hidden layer so the inputs come from the
input layer
and they get processed in the hidden
layer and then you get the output in the
output layer
so let's take a little bit of a detailed
look into the working of a neural
network
so let's say we want to classify some
images
between dogs and cats how do we do this
this is known as a classification
process and we are trying to use neural
networks and deep learning to implement
this classification so how do we do that
so this is how
it works so you have four layer
neural network there is an input layer
there is an output layer
and then there are two hidden layers and
what we do is
we provide labeled training data
which means these images are fed to the
network
with the label saying that okay this is
a cat the neural network is
allowed to process it and come up with a
prediction
saying whether it is a cat or a dog and
obviously in the beginning
there may be mistakes a cat may be
classified as a dog so we then say that
okay this
is wrong this output is wrong but every
time it predicts correctly we say yes
this output is correct so
that learning process so it will go back
make some changes
to its weights and biases we again feed
these
inputs and it will give us the output we
will check whether it is correct or not
and so on so this is a
iterative process which is known as the
training process
so we are training the neural network
and what happens
in the training process these weights
and biases you remember there were
weights like w1 w2 and so on so these
weights and biases
keep changing every time you feed
these which is known as an epoch so
there are multiple
iterations every iteration is known as
an epoch and each time the weights are
dated
to make sure that the maximum number of
images are classified correctly so
once again what is the input this input
could be like
1000 images of cats and dogs and they
are labeled because we know which is a
cat and which is a dog
and we feed those thousand images the
neural network will
initially assign some weights and biases
for each neuron and it will try to
process
extract the features from the images and
it will try to come up with a prediction
for each image and that prediction that
is calculated by the network
is compared with the actual value
whether it is a cat or a dog and that's
how the
error is calculated so let's say there
are a thousand images
and in the first run only 500 of them
have been correctly classified that
means we are getting only 50
accuracy so we feed that information
back to the network
further update these weights and biases
for each of the neurons and we run this
these inputs once again it will try to
calculate extract the features and it
will try to predict
which of these is cats and dogs and this
time let's say out of thousand
700 of them have been predicted
correctly so that means in the second
iteration
the accuracy has increased from 50
percent to 70 percent
all right then we go back again we feed
this maybe for a third iteration
fourth iteration and so on and slowly
and
steadily the accuracy of this network
will keep increasing
and it may reach probably you never know
90 95 percent
and there are several parameters that
are known as hyper parameters that need
to be
changed and tweaked and that is the
overall training process and ultimately
at some point we say okay you will
probably never reach 100
accuracy but then we set a limit saying
that okay if we receive
95 percent accuracy that is good enough
for our application and then we say okay
our training process is done
so that is the way training happens and
once the training
is done now with the training data set
the system has
let's say seen all these thousand images
therefore what we do is
the next step like in any normal machine
learning process
we do the testing where we take a fresh
set of images
and we feed it to the network the fresh
set which it has not seen before as a
part of the training process
and this is again nothing new in deep
learning this was there in machine
learning as well
so you feed the test images and then
find out
whether we are getting a similar
accuracy or not so maybe
that accuracy may reduce a little bit
while training you may get 98
and then for test you may get 95 percent
but there shouldn't be a drastic drop
like for example you get 98 in training
and then you get 50 percent or 40
with the test that means your network
has not learned
you may have to retrain your network so
that is the
way neural network training works and
remember the whole process is
about changing these weights and biases
and coming up with the optimal
values of these weights and biases so
that the accuracy
is the maximum possible all right so a
little bit
more detail about how this whole thing
works so this is
known as forward propagation which is
the data or the information is going
in the forward direction the inputs are
taken
weighted summation is done bias is added
here
and then that is fed to the activation
function
and then that is that comes out as an
output so that is forward propagation
and
the output is compared with the actual
value and that will give us the
error the difference between them is the
error and in technical terms that is
also known
as our cost function and this is what we
would like to
minimize there are different ways of
defining the cost function but one of
the
simplest ways is mean square error
so it is nothing but the square of the
difference of the errors or the sum
of the squares of the difference of the
errors and this is also nothing new we
have probably
if you're familiar with machine learning
you must have come across this
mean square now there are different ways
of defining cost function
it need not always be the mean square
error but the most common one
is this so you define this cost function
and
you ask the system to minimize this
error
so we use what is known as an
optimization
function to minimize this error and
the error itself sent back to the system
as feedback and that is known as
back propagation and so this is the cost
function and how do we optimize the cost
function
we use what is known as gradient descent
so the gradient descent mechanism
identifies
how to change the weights and biases
so that the cost function is minimized
and there is also what is known as the
rate
or the learning rate that is what is
shown here as slower
and faster so you need to specify what
should be the learning rate
now if the learning rate is very small
then it will probably take very long
to train whereas if the learning rate is
very high then
it will appear to be faster but then it
will probably
never what is known as converge now what
is convergence now we are talking about
a few terms here convergence is like
this
this is a representation of convergence
so the whole
idea of gradient descent is to optimize
the cost function or minimize the cost
function
in order to do that we need to represent
the cost function as this curve
we need to come to this minimum value
that is what is known as the
minimization of the cost function
now what happens if we have the learning
rate
very small is that it will take very
long
to come to this point on the other hand
if you have large higher learning rate
what will happen is
instead of stopping here it will cross
over
because the learning rate is high and
then it has to come back
so it will result in what is known as
like an oscillation so it will never
come to this point which is known as
convergence instead it will go
back and forth so these are known as
hyper parameters the learning rate and
so on and these have to be
those numbers or those values we can
determine
typically using trial and error out of
experience we we try to find out these
values so that is the gradient descent
mechanism to
optimize the cost function and that is
what is used to
train our neural network this is another
representation
of how the training process works and
here in this example we are trying to
classify
these images whether they are cats or
dogs
and as you can see actually each image
is fed in each time one image is fed
rather
and these values of x1 x2 up to xn
are the pixel values within this image
okay
so those values are then taken and for
each of those
values a weight is multiplied and then
it goes to the next layer and then to
the next layer and so on
ultimately it comes as the output layer
and it
gives an output as whether it is a dog
or a cat remember
the output will never be a named output
so these would be like
a zero or a one and we say okay zero
corresponds to dogs and one corresponds
to cats so that is the way
it typically happens this is a binary
classification
we have similar situations where there
can be multiple
classes which means that there will be
multiple more neurons
in the output layer okay so this is once
again
a quick representation of how the
forward propagation and the backward
propagation works
so the information is going in this
direction
which is basically the forward
propagation and at the output level
we find out what is the cost function
the difference is basically sent back as
part of the backward propagation and
gradient descent then
adjust the weights and biases for the
next iteration
this happens iteratively till the cost
function
is minimized and that is when we say
the whole the network has converged or
the training process has converged
and there can be situations where
convergence may not happen
in rare cases but by and large the
network will converge and after maybe
a few iterations it could be tens of
iterations or hundreds of iterations
depending on what exactly the number of
iterations can vary
and then we say okay we are getting a
certain
accuracy and we say that is our
threshold maybe 90
accuracy we stop at that and we say that
the system is trained
the trained model is then deployed for
production and so on so that is the
way the neural network training happens
okay so that is the way classification
works in deep learning using neural
network
and this slide is an animation of this
whole process
as you can see the forward propagation
the data is going
forward from the input layer to the
output layer and there is an output
and the error is calculated the cost
function
is calculated and that is fed back as a
part of backward propagation
and that whole process repeats once
again
okay so remember in neural networks the
training process is nothing but
the finding the best values of
the weights and biases for each and
every neuron
in the network that's all training of
neural network consists of
finding the optimal values of the
weights and biases
so that the accuracy is maximum
all right so with that we come to the
end of the session
we all have a great day thank you very
much
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here